hi everyone
my name is daniel lopezano and i am the
atomic absorption
microwave plasma product manager at
agilent technologies
i am joined today by jenny nelson and
yarn chung
who have over 25 years experience in the
petrochemical industry
working in various oil companies
they are also the energy and chemical
specialists at agilent
thank you for joining today as we have
some great news on a new astm method
for the elemental analysis of crude oil
and residual fuel
firstly i would like to introduce to you
the agilent 4210
mpaes elemental analysis
that runs on air it's simple
proven and efficient microwave plasma
atomic emission spectroscopy is a novel
atomic emission spectroscopy technique
the mpas journey starts back in 2004
and 2006 with our first patents being
released
in november of 2011 agilent released the
first commercially available
microwave plasma system the 4100 mpaes
in january of 2014 the second generation
instrument the 4200 mpaes was released
featuring new innovations including a
new waveguide
and torch and new firmware and software
in september 2016 the latest version was
released
the 4210 mpaes which could be now fitted
with
a number of new accessories including
the integrated avs4 valve
and the isometric temperature controlled
spray chamber
there are also new consumables released
the oneneb series 2
and the inert torch
an update in march of 2018 brought with
it a new waveguide kit
and a new software version now with
windows 10 support
it also added in a number of instrument
tests
designed to allow users to do a health
check and monitor performance of their
instrument
to give information about problems so
they can be fixed by the user
our most recent news is in june of 2020
with the release
of a new astm standard test method
the astm d832
for crude oil and residual fuel oils
it's a simple dilute and shoot method
for nickel
iron vanadium sulfur and more
and we have more information to share
throughout this presentation
microwave plasma emission follows a very
similar path
to that of other optical emission
spectroscopy techniques
like icp oes a sample is presented to
the instrument via a sample introduction
system
through a torch containing a plasma
the plasma in an mpas is made up from
nitrogen
that has a temperature of 5000 degrees
kelvin
which is hotter than that of flame
atomic absorption
this allows for better performance
samples are desolvated atomized and
excited in the plasma
to produce light emissions at atomic
specific wavelengths
the light then enters the monochromator
and detector where they can be
quantified within
the instrument software so how does the
mp work
the 4210 mpas uses nitrogen extracted
from air
using the agilent 4107 nitrogen
generator
the microwave saw is the heart of the
technology
and the image shows the interaction of
the magnetic and electric fields from a
magnetron
that are focused into an iris to sustain
a toroidal nitrogen plasma
the torch is vertically orientated and
offers
a stable introduction of aerosol samples
through a classical
easy to use sample introduction system
similar to that of an icp oes
the aerosols that are presented to the
torch contain elements
that when they're excited produce
emissions of light
these light emissions are viewed axially
from the end of the plasma
and directed into the fast scanning
monochromatic
optics
the emissions are channeled along the
path of the monochromator
where they are separated into the
wavelength of interest
the atomic specific wavelengths are
measured by a high efficiency
ccd detector where they can be measured
and quantified against intensities of
known concentration
that form a celebration the 4210
mpa has noticeable features that benefit
elemental analysis requirements it has a
low cost of ownership
nitrogen used in the mpaes is cheaper
than acetylene or argon
and it becomes even cheaper when you're
generating nitrogen
from air this also eliminates ongoing
gas supply costs
the mpas also doesn't require hollow
cathode lamps
or a chiller
has bed performance with lower detection
limits and a larger dynamic range than
flame atomic absorption
it is safe to operate with no flammable
gases
and no manual cylinder handling
and is easy to use the intuitive mp
expert software can be operated by users
with minimal training
and the sample introduction is easy plug
and play design
the 4210 mp aes offers significant
safety improvements over other
techniques
the nitrogen plasma eliminates the
flammable gases of atomic absorption
which is really important in
petrochemical laboratories
that have lots of flammable chemicals in
them
the microwave plasma also allows for
unattended analysis
the second safety advantage is around
personnel and operator safety
by using the 4107 nitrogen generator it
completely removes the handling of
compressed gas cylinders
it also eliminates the need for ongoing
gas supply
and this is advantageous at remote
locations where it can be difficult to
get in
acetylene or argon
the standard sample introduction is
simple and robust
the 4210 comes with the one neb2
a high efficiency inert nebulizer
it also comes with a double pass spray
chamber for effective
fine aerosol transfer to the plasma and
an easy fit
one piece torch
the sample introduction has been
designed for ease of use in mind
the easy fit torch is easily handled and
can be loaded in three simple steps
firstly open the torch loader
second insert the torch and third
close the torch loader handle the torch
is automatically aligned
and all gas connections are
automatically connected
no further operator interaction is
required
the spray chamber and nebulizer are
simply clamped
and locked and the quick fit fittings
connect the tubing in place
agilent offers a range of accessories to
optimize performance
for the petrochemical industry we have
the external gas control
module or the egcm which allows for air
injection into the plasma to prevent
carbon buildup when running
organic samples it also facilitates
controlled purging of the optics for low
uv analysis including sulfur
and as it's easily controlled through
the mv expert software
the sps4 is a fast versatile
high capacity auto sampler and is
compatible with the mpaes
as well as the other agilent atomic
spectroscopy products
including atomic absorption icp-oes
and icp-ms the mp
expert software is simple to use with an
intuitive workflow
guiding the operator through the
analysis steps
it features auto background correction
removing the need for users to place the
background markers
it is flexible with a detailed system
dashboard and has the option
for online remote operation with the
automation software pack
it also has powerful reporting tools
the mp expert software has been designed
to be user friendly
with an easy to follow workflow taking
the user through
all the steps leading to analysis
the instrument controls are all at the
top of the screen
and in the same window we can see the
results
replicate data emission spectrum and
calibration
np expert also features applet mode for
the simplest steps to sample analysis
in three easy clicks you simply need to
select
the applet icon from the desktop to load
a method
light the plasma enter the sample labels
and press run
i will now pass over to jenny who will
give you more details about our exciting
new astm
d8322 thank you for your attention
thank you daniel so today i would like
to talk to you
about our astm method d8322
uh-20 and this is the standard test
method
for determination of elements in
residual fuels and crude oil
by microwave plasma atomic emission
spectroscopy
you can see in the picture the method on
the astm website
it is now available for you to go check
out and download
so i wanted to give you a little bit of
background on how this method started
so it was probably about six years ago
in about 2014
that i was working with our
collaborators at chevron
and we were talking about this new
wonderful technology that agilent came
out with the mpaes
and they were very interested in
learning more about it
and maybe doing a study to see you know
how well this
instrument could perform with their very
difficult samples
so we decided to work with crude oils
first
and we ran you know the gamut of crude
oils they we had a huge range with
all different crude oils having
different apis and we really put this
thing to the test
and they were very impressed with the
results that the mpaes could give so we
published this paper in energy and fuels
after we published this paper we
published an agilent
application note based on that work so
that everybody would have access to it
because we know not everybody has access
to all published peer-reviewed journals
after that study was complete we decided
let's try something even more difficult
samples and so
we decided to try some petroleum
fractions
heavier fractions that were a thousand
degrees fahrenheit and higher
so we ran these on the mpaes as well and
we had great results again
and we published this again in energy
and fuels
in 2017. we followed
this method again with an agilent
application note so everybody would have
access
to the study that we did and
after we completed these two studies we
decided
that this would be a really great
instrument
and method for the petroleum industry
this instrument like we've already
stated or daniel already stated
is uh suited very well to be
in remote locations because it doesn't
require argon
so chevron is a company that has a lot
of satellite labs
and satellite facilities in remote
locations
and so you know maybe this would be a
good alternative
instrument for them so we
did a lot of work and i'll share that
with you soon but we were able to get
this final method so
now there is an astm method using the
mpaes
for the determination of elements in
residual fuels and crude oils
and that was all based off of the
preliminary work that we did
in those two energy income energy
in fuels papers that i just showed you
so a lot of people
um know that we have a astm method but
aren't quite aware of
the years of work that went into this
method
before we even started this astm method
so
that was just a little bit of background
and definitely have to
thank our collaborators at chevron for
um for all their hard work doing this
as well okay so here is the timeline
for the astm d8322
so i find it very interesting how long
some of these test methods uh
take to get approved but it's a it's
quite a lot of work for the people
that are involved so kudos to all the
people that work on astm methods
so we originally started this project
again after we published that second
paper
in energy and fuels and we had this
project approved by um our managers so
that we could try to
get this uh method you know developed
and proposed to astm
so that was the first step and that
happened in you can see spring
of 2017. that was the first
step the second step is that we had a
proposal to astm
in october of 2017. we started to work
with
two collaborators they were
the chevron who we worked with before
and enroll
who was another collaborator for
our biofuel version of an mpaes method
so we had the work item you can see
right here which was work item
56841 which is for standard test method
for determination of metals in crude oil
and residual fuel
oils okay and then
in december of 2017
astm denied our balloting with this
method
and the reason for that was that this
was brand new technology
there wasn't a single method in astm
that used our
microwave plasma atomic emissions
spectrometer and so this was a new for
everybody it wasn't an icp oas
an icp ms something that they'd seen
before or a gc which is tons of messes
with gc and other
you know instrumentation so we had to do
um more work and so in january of 2018
we decided to work with an astm
statistical
expert so that we could run a pilot
study
and this was before running an
interlaboratory study
so the next thing was that in july 2018
we started or we finished our pilot
study
this pilot study uh was working with six
laboratories the six laboratories that
we worked with
were um agilent
in santa clara and then we worked with
chevron which is in richmond california
up the road and we worked with enroll
which is in colorado
and bv in texas and wake forest
university
in georgia and then we worked with
sgs in the netherlands and we got some
really good results
from the different laboratories
so the next thing we did is work on our
ils
so this is where we had multiple labs
all over the globe
running this method and most of these
laboratories with the exception of you
know the agilent
labs and uh waste forest
none of these laboratories had ever run
or some of them had never even heard of
an mpaes before
so this was quite a feat to be able to
place instruments all over the globe
train these folks and get them to
participate in this ios
and so you can see we now have the
addition of an additional agilent lab
and we added um a university
um in san carlos in spain
and total uh in france
and nestle in finland and sgs
in saudi arabia and we also added
another agilent lab in melbourne
australia so you can see we
really cover the globe and it again it
was a lot of hard work
and i know because i traveled to the
majority of these places
and worked with these folks but it was a
really great experience
and i was very happy when all the labs
had turned in their data
and we had really good results
so the next step was that all the data
was compiled by the astm statistician
and in may 19 in may
2019 we had a standard ballot with the
subcommittee
and then we had
our final method our astm method
d8322 finally finalized in june
2020 so you can see that this just
brings a smile to my face because i
started working on
this project probably back in
2014 so i'm very happy now to see that
the astm
has accepted the mpaes method
okay so i just wanted to share with you
a few results from the ios
um i think that if you really want to
know more about this method the best
thing to do
is to reach out to me individually
or if you'd like to get the method from
astm that's a great idea as well
okay one thing that i want to point out
to you is
that the crude oil in fuel oil is all
run
in the same method so you can run both
of sample types
within the same method and you can see
how we set up
the method here so this is a method
sequence
let me put my laser pointer on and i can
show you
so this is the calibration for
the mpaes and you can see all the
different elements across the top
okay and then you'll see we have some qc
and then the first set of 10
are actually crude oil samples okay
all these samples were sent blind by a
third-party lab that works with astm
so none of the labs knew what samples
they were getting they just knew
if they were to be running it on day one
so they had day one
day two day three and day four
and they knew which day to run the
samples but they didn't know what the
samples were
so these were the first 10 samples i
guess for this day
and you can see this was actually day
one since there's a d z one this was
sample one d
one and it was crude oil so they did the
ten samples
uh the crude for the crude oil and then
they did some qc
and then they ran the ten uh residual
fuel oil samples after that and then
some qc
so again you can run all these elements
for the mix of samples you don't have to
run a separate
crude oil method to a separate fuel oil
method this is run
in one single method okay so that's very
important and good to know all right
next slide
okay so here's just a few results i just
randomly picked
um day three for lab three i don't even
can't even tell you who lab three is uh
right now but so these are results for
uh vanadium iron and nickel and you can
see this is a calibration
curve which is overlaid
for the calibration of vanadium so on
top we can see the
the
peak and then on the bottom we can see
the the curve and you can see
this lab did a really good job they did
uh four nines
in our correlation coefficient of four
nines
and we have very linear calibration
curve
the next one we're looking at is iron
and you can see
we also have a very linear calibration
curve for this
and we had a correlation coefficient of
four nines as well and then
the third element that we'll show is
nickel
and you can see that we had also very
uh linear correlation our calibration
curve
and we had a correlation coefficient of
i think uh 0.998 so that is great
okay so now i just want to show you the
method test ranges
so this is the one for crude oil and you
can see
the different elements that we're
looking at for crude oil
and you can see iron vanadium
nickel calcium sodium potassium and
sulfur
okay and you can see that most of these
uh elements go down quite low so this is
all in milligrams per kilogram
and you can see um
iron goes down to has a range from 0.1
all the way up to 208 and all these were
calculated
based on the ils of 12 labs by the astm
statistician okay now you can see the
method test range for the residual fuel
oil
and you can see we have vanadium nickel
calcium sodium aluminum
silica zinc and sulfur
and we have very good ranges for
each of these elements and this is what
i wanted to share with you today
and so i think that now we are going to
move over to some q a with
daniel myself and jan and thank you for
um your interest in the astm d8322
method again i'm very excited
that this method has finally been
finalized okay
great thank you thank you jenny for
sharing that information with us
there are some questions that have come
in from users that have already
looked at the d83 22 standard
i wonder if you and yarn could share
your experience with us
to help answer some of these questions
so the first question from your
participation in the mpas
study what do you think the instrument
could be most useful to the lab
in terms of ease of use and cost
reduction
thanks daniel that is a really good
question um i would
say um probably
the ease of use of the mpaes is
huge um i was able to go into each of
the
interlaboratory studies participants
that were
working on the mpaes method with us
and i had to go in and train the folks
how to use
the mpaes and they all learned how to
use it really really quickly
there was only one laboratory that was
familiar and had an
mpaes in their lab and this was one of
the university labs
but with the exception of that one lab
the other
11 labs had never even seen an
mpaes before there was icp oes users and
icp ms users but no one had
specifically worked with an mpa yes and
i was extremely impressed
with all the participants being able to
pick it up really fast and learning
how to use the instrument understand the
instrument
and be able to work with the software um
the software is really simple and
intuitive
and again it really impressed me as far
as
cost reduction for the mtas
not having argon is a huge bonus
i recently visited a lab here that
has oes icp oya systems and icpms
systems but multiple
units of both and they spend about 4
000 a week on argon that's a lot of
money for a lab
and even if they were able to move a
fraction of their test methods
uh onto an mpa yes that could save a lot
of money
another thing that came up at this
laboratory and i'm sure
it's a problem for other laboratories um
around
is that there potentially could be um
times when argon is hard to get even
laboratories that are in
you know an urban area a city where
normally argon delivery is not a problem
during these crazy times um especially
this covert 19 time you never know and
sometimes you don't get your
your argon delivery as scheduled
and to be able to have some of your
crucial test methods
um having a backup method on an mpa yes
where argon
is not needed people can see a lot of
value in that
um yeah i hope that answers that
question daniel
yeah i think that's a really great with
great feedback about the method and
it's great to share that the benefits of
the mp can provide so
thank you for that um another follow-up
question jenny
how do you think different labs like a
production
or an r d lab would find mpis
helpful in different aspects
well that's a good question so i think
that they would benefit from
a lot of the points i just said above so
again it's
really easy to use and very intuitive
software
and a lot of the things like you talked
about earlier the ease of
putting the torches in and taking the
torches out and
making things very simple for people
that's really good because some of those
labs
don't necessarily have the um
you know a lot of advanced
technicians will say maybe they have
more entry level technicians
or they have people that are running
multiple instruments
um and have to learn kind of like be the
jack of all trades and run a gc and lc
and
mpas or an icp-o-s and so they might not
have the
um technical knowledge of some of the
other ic
icp oas and ms users but they're able
they would be easily
able to be trained on an mp aes it's
just it's really that simple
and another advantage for production lab
would be that soon we'll probably have
two astm methods
we have the astm d8322 method which we
talked about today
and soon we'll have another astm method
hopefully we have
another work item so the methods will
already be complete and all they have to
do
is hit go if they have the template for
our methods in the mpa yes
yeah so that really leads to the
benefits that
i talked about without mp about being
easy to use
um it's all been designed to be really
easy to use and then we have the added
benefit of
applet mode which it really doesn't take
much for
a user to get up and and running and can
be a jack of all trades as simple as
loading the method and hitting run
so um that's really great great to hear
that we can we can benefit
um a wide range of users
uh so yarn from your experience in the
oil and gas industry
is there any other applications that you
could see to be
used with the mpaes
yeah sure and i think in oil and gas
at a lab in a remote location can really
find good use of the mpaes especially
that it only runs on air
and instead of argon and like jenny
mentioned that argon can sometimes
really hard to find
especially in a remote location so with
the mpaes
with the nitrogen generator along with
the instrument
then a lab in a remote location can
really find good use for that
um one example i can think of is some
upstream labs
and you know some upstream their
drooling size is in the middle of
nowhere but they do need to test
whatever the product that they have
recovered from the ground
or for downstream labs that uh maybe in
the terminal lab
for example that are often in a location
that are really hard to get
the resources are really hard to get to
but the product
i really need to be tested before they
ship
out to their customers so lab in remote
locations
can can find good use for the mp
yan that actually reminds me um
of one of my trips so when i used to
work at an oil and gas company
i would have to travel to remote
locations
you know where you're taking multiple
planes sometimes a helicopter
to get over to these terminal labs um
well i went i took a trip
once to nigeria and again it was like
like you said offshore
or well it was at a terminal and so we
had to take a special flight to get to
that terminal
and i was there to do two weeks of icp
oes training so it was back-to-back
training one week for one
shift and the next week for another
shift and
they had such a hard time getting argon
for their icp oes
and i remember we had one tank to do
all the training for two weeks and that
really scared me because i never had
that limitation before being you know
in california and uh
getting argon is not normally an issue
for us here to having to
really um what's the word i'm looking
for
be be uh careful with how much argon we
were using for each of the different
like
experiments and learning um skills that
we were doing every day
we would turn the instrument on warm it
up really quickly
do what we were going to do and then
turn it back off again there was no
leaving it on
and you know running extra things or
like playing with
playing with much so um so that
definitely made me think of uh
the example you gave uh
yeah that's a yeah a situation that's
ideal
you know and it's a risk that can be run
and running in
uh an icp-oes and that's what and
acetylene is the same
you know you're relying on that that
delivery all the time so
by having our nitrogen generator you
don't have to worry about any of that
and
you know you just run it off air and
it's really it's really great
so um that's fantastic
we'll hear that we can actually be
beneficial to those buttons
so yeah still i wish we would have had
an mpa yes at that lab
so another question for yarn how about
refinery labs and the third-party labs
that they send their samples to
how do you think the mpas can be useful
to those labs
yeah so i think refinery lab can really
find the mpaes to be very useful
as far as i know refinery labs are
really tight in budget most of the time
so now they they can save the cause and
using argon like jenny will mention
earlier with four thousand dollar a week
that uh our mpaes can become very
attractive to them now especially our
mpaes method is the astm method
then we'll make the implementation even
more attractive
and this goes to the third party lab as
well
we find some refinery they are not
equipped to have a full scale lab
so often times they will send their
sample out to third-party labs for
certification of the monitoring of the
refinery
processes so now with the standard
method associated with our mpaes
then the third-party lab can really uh
make use of the mpaes for their to
reduce their cost and as well as for
their ease of operation
that's great yeah um it adds more
elements as we've heard from
from jenny's presentation um so we can
actually add more capabilities and
combine some things and make it easier
for for all parties involved especially
those third-party labs that are running
multiple different methods yes like you
said daniel
we're able to do more than just iron
nickel and vanadium like a lot of
astm crude oil methods do this method is
also able to do
calcium sodium aluminum silica
zinc potassium and sulfur so that's a
great addition to
the um to the element list for different
laboratories
yeah so it's all in one and and we can
do more elements
on the one technique and on the one
instrument without having to
to cross over into other techniques
yeah so some users have also been onto
the asgm website
and saw that there's another work item
coming up on the mpas
for biodiesel what's that about
oh that's a great question daniel so yes
so
we had another um method running
concurrently
with the astm 8322 method which was the
one we just talked about but we're also
working on
a biofuels method and if you give me one
second i can
share my screen and show you the work
item number
which hopefully this will become a final
method very soon
so let me switch over to share my screen
with you guys
okay so now you should be able to see my
screen
and you can see that this biofuels
method like i said is a work item right
now
and it's work item 56916
and this is the new test method for
determination of metals in biodiesel
in organic mode by mpaes
and so this is really exciting so we've
already done the ios
and we are working through the comments
of the reviewers right now and so
hopefully very soon
this will be also a final method at astm
just a little bit of background on this
method if you've got time
um so this started um from our close
work
with um one of the researchers uh teresa
allman
at enroll which is the national
renewable energy laboratory
and she's on the committee for biofuels
and that committee needed a method
that could analyze metals in their
biofuels
so working with teresa and the group we
were able to come up with this method
that meets elder needs
so that was very exciting and another
exciting thing is
theresa and her group at nrel they've
recently
published this technical report where
they used our mpaes
and this method that we developed with
them and they've
um published it on their nrel website so
if anybody's interested they could go
check out this
technical report where they use this
method
to look at biodiesel blends
so in real life uh samples so it was
really good
very interesting i think that's a very
exciting news
that um like all the more renewable
research in our
mpaes are able to participate in that
yeah so adding elemental analysis to
something that traditionally hasn't had
it but also providing
an instrument that's really easy to use
so traditional users
actually can get up and running as fast
as possible
yeah and i actually went to theresa's
lab to train her on how to use the mpa
yes
and she this was like a totally new
technology for her i mean she's an
extremely
bright researcher and you know
you know one of the best in her field
but this was all new for her and she
caught on
you know i think i was there for two
days and she she was able to run the
instrument and you know produce all this
data
and this technical report so um
she's definitely a testament to how uh
even a newbie to the atomic spectroscopy
world can jump in and use the mpaes to
get started and get
get the data that they need that's great
so thank you jenny and jan for joining
me today
and thank you all for joining our
webinar today
on the astm d8322
for more information about the method
or the mpas feel please feel free to
contact
us myself jenny or yarn
and our email addresses are there below
thank you
you